[Music]
good morning guys today's a new day it
is Monday April 6 so I don't know how
many days it's been since the last time
I picked up the camera but yeah today
we're vlogging and it's funny because I
actually showered and they did my hair
and I even put a little bit lip gloss
and I'm even wearing a bra I was like oh
[ __ ] I put makeup on but then I thought
about putting makeup on no like me so
sorry as good as I'm gonna get today so
a lot of stuff that's been going on
around the house nothing huge
major I think that has happened I
haven't showed you yet
um I know change a couple things over
there sort of a little bit got this here
hasn't been put up yet I move to that
there just a quick oh yeah like we set
up the Xbox up here oh oh look at this
the theater snack baskets so I brought
up a whole bunch of snacks for us to
munch on and then in here I also have
some more snacks there's some cheez-its
in there we have just been fold
degenerate this this whole quarantine
time we've just been chilling up here oh
and I also got a new Apple TV so now
there's an Apple TV in our bedroom in
the loft and downstairs so has been
enjoying his new cat tree that's not
gonna live there we just moved it for
now it's been there but we got a huge
package today look at this look at this
beast taking up like our entire entryway
here so this thing here it is an armoire
and we're gonna be putting it upstairs
and it's really pretty it's a mirrored
armoire kind of hard to say I have to
try really hard to say it that's gonna
go up there hopefully it looks good
that's that's been like my vision is to
make it look really nice up there and
you changed this to say take a deep
breath and
I like it and ever since I've put it
here every time I look at it I'm always
like so the reason why I did that is
because I have the klom app sponsor our
podcasts but they don't sponsor this
this video but just shout out for the
comment I'm a huge freaking fan and it's
like this meditation app and every time
you open the app it says take a deep
breath and I just like it cuz I'm like
I'd like a nice reminder to just inhale
and like I don't know just breathing
just makes you feel good so I did that
to the board that Kevin gave us our
realtor if you wrote on there like Tim
Casey and like welcome to adulting like
that but yeah I changed it so that oh
yeah we don't have out here anymore
because pretty soon we're gonna be
getting our couch the new couch that I
got I got like an l-shaped sectional
Casey's using the bathroom over there
but we got an l-shaped sectional thing
coming in a couch so that's gonna go
here but in the meantime we moved this
out to the garage because we actually
want to charge
oh boy wait before the garage I'm super
excited about this though pantry is
practically done I got all of the pantry
accessory thingies like that stuff and
then this stuff and then this stuff and
then this stuff and then this stuff and
this I love it look I got to use my
label maker too so I freaking love all
of this this is my my project my baby my
creation here I think I did a pretty
dang good job I'm really proud of this
pantry tada
look at the garage just still looks like
a mess to you but to us this is
incredibly organized so what we did is
we moved the stuff that we're keeping /
my aunts gonna come and pick up cuz she
wants some of this stuff
my mom's keeping this and the
coffeemaker and all of this - the bikes
and the ladder but all of this is what
we're trying to sell and this is where
we put the other big couch and we
actually put the legs back on though in
case whoever wants to take this and buy
it at least they got the legs but yeah
we have like old
sir the bookshelves Isaac's black couch
are you trying to get rid of that
mattress and the bed frame as well
actually these two things here and then
all of this here and then all of that my
aunts gonna be taking and then got to
get rid of those lamps to we're keeping
the umbrella this is for our shoes so
we're keeping this this whole thing here
oh my gosh
it was insane because Casey and I just
kept trying to like shuffle things
around and then I was trying to use like
my Tetris mind I'm like okay if we move
this here and if we move that there
should perfectly align and so I was just
like really trying to make the most out
of the space and it actually worked out
really beautifully because now we can
access that door without having to go
all the way around all the junk that was
the way it was before I mean we could
still actually go around this couch if
we really wanted to because we made sure
to leave enough space but I don't know
we're pretty happy that we just gotta
like go through the bikes a little bit
where we can access that door
Casey's very happy about that because
his car is right outside that door so
this was like a huge accomplishment when
we did it we felt really really
satisfied with it the garage is is a big
thing oh let me Ahmad movie end when ov
yes yes Joe sudden Joe sighs Joe sudden
yeah shy in the morning for you to show
you that everything we did top of the
market fall 33 in the afternoon oh yeah
that's another thing I wanted to talk
about so it has been a struggle to keep
a normal schedule like I don't know if
you guys are experiencing this too but
for me actually for everyone in this
house we have slowly been going to sleep
later and later there was this one night
warm it went to sleep like at 3:30 in
the morning and it's like how is this
happening but these are Gino's yeah
Magina
program exactly all the gamers and stuff
yeah that has been something I've been
trying to battle is like okay stop going
to sleep so late and then waking up
earlier today was the earliest I have
woken up in a couple weeks and I woke up
at like 8:30 9:00 like 8:30 or 9:00 and
I was like whoa this is so early
compared to how late we've all been
waking up usually which has been around
12 yeah this whole morning you know we
got breakfast we showered we got dressed
and all that so it wasn't time wasted
but you today you bought ready you did
your hair it actually did my hair I'm
like look good going nothing wearing
this hat is I want my hat when I'm lazy
and I'm like I gotta get yeah you know
you know you haircut be like worth it
cuz no it's very long now it's already
been two weeks since the haircut like
it's getting your wolfin yeah it's wolfy
on the sides man
oh well mustache that didn't survive
very long either yeah yeah just how do
you rid of it all gotta feel good about
myself and you gotta feel good about is
what we're doing within these walk walls
for a house yeah yeah or else we're
gonna go nuts I'm so depressing out
there I know
and then today we woke up and it was
raining so it's been very gloomy but I
feel good because I don't know like like
what you're saying I feel good that I
actually like showered and dressed and I
put on a bra yeah like I don't know it
really does a lot to your to your psyche
to just get ready and like get up and
like I don't know I've been reading a
lot of people having tips on like how to
survive this little self quarantine
stage of the world and a lot of people
are saying it's important to keep a
schedule just keep your life as normal
as possible as before the quarantine
yeah I don't know I feel like I've kind
of been struggling to do that in terms
of like waking up early going to sleep
early and all that stuff but other than
that I feel like I've been pretty
productive except for some days what
we're just like yeah let's just not do
anything and then we veg out and we
enjoy the theater room
oh man yesterday
and I we signed up to match your class
and it's so cute because we're like oh
it's like we're two like college girls
like college besties having like our
course together or whatever but we ended
up doing the Kelly worse
fuller interior design course and it was
really informative it was kind of cool
next tonight we're doing the negotiating
one with Chris boss I think his name is
that's the one we're really excited for
but I don't know just like keeping
myself engaged and I think because
yesterday when I was texting Mickey I
told Casey how this cracked me up but I
was like yeah you know I really love
learning new things because when I'm
learning I could feel my brain getting
all tingly like I feel like it's working
oh yeah yeah that's not haha but I also
sat down at the piano and I spent like a
good I don't know like an hour an hour
and a half or something like trying to
learn from the iPad and just like I
don't know there's these moments so when
I'm learning that I stop like I just
take like a quick pause and I'm like my
brain is tingling it's so stupid i crack
myself up I would with Kelly from your
design course approve of this wall are
you pronounce that word I know I was
saying that feeling like I have trouble
saying it on war no more I keep thinking
I'm more yeah it's not a more you called
it at mode once and I was like it's an
armoire armoire
it sounds like a made-up name armoire
it's French or something
I used to pronounce in French then voila
I don't know yeah I don't know but I
honestly like Kelly chick her style is
like something not even close to what I
would do with my spaces but just like
her her thought process behind it like
her whole like process is what I found
really a philosophy very insightful yeah
like where she draws inspiration from
and like things like that that's what I
kind of liked
I wouldn't say she would approve or
disapprove of the armoire is just kind
of like she has a whole nother style
based on the the hole in your face
knowing he gave me yesterday I feel like
she would approve of this the mirrors so
we had this whole thing about getting
mirrors for the house or not I don't
know I'm here to make the house look
cheap and then it was like no mirrors
are expensive they're gonna make the
house look really nice and I'm like you
know not are some like mirrors and then
the in the course the Corps says mirrors
are nice so the whole thing I was saying
is that first of all marriages are very
expensive
second of all mirrors are a great
element to incorporate into your space
when it's a small space because it makes
it feel bigger and that's what I was
trying to tell you that especially
upstairs it's so small and compact that
adding a mirror will make it feel bigger
so that's all I was saying so that's why
I brought the course out and I'm like oh
yeah I told you it's expensive and it
makes it feel bigger I was wrong but hey
we have a mirror now and we're also
saying we're hoping it's already fully
built yes that would be great because in
that way yeah no that won't be great
because this thing is huge and we have
to get get it through the staircase
which is narrow and like yeah that's
true and there's the upside and the
downside to it being built or not being
built there however rather be able to
take part and just take pieces of
whatever true this other box to by the
way is we got the garage storing rack
thingy so you know how I showed you guys
the garage well eventually we want to
install the thingy up on the ceiling so
then there will be more storage because
there's a very little storage to begin
with thank you Wow oh and then this look
look-look-look-look I'm so excited to
show you guys this I got this wallpaper
from Amazon and look it's so pretty and
the reason why I picked this one is
because I kind of wanted a tie in this
piece to the wallpaper and this
wallpaper is going to live in this wall
like on this wall that's the idea this
whole
wallets gonna be covered with this
thingamabob I'm excited for this
bathroom because that last night you
were also shopping for mirrors mirrors
your end yeah even looking at wears ugly
yes it's the ugly mirror first thing my
mom said up at her house a critique wise
was this mirror she was like what how
much money you spent on this house and
this is the Mary they give you keep like
you know like I really I mean alright
like the cheapest murder you could
possibly get I feel like true because
yeah look at the there's like no frame
or anything and then there's also holes
yeah I never know there's been so I took
my first poop in here I level there I
mean I mean poopit that's the first time
I'd noticed it - and I sat down and I
was like hey there's holes like right
there they didn't even fill those holes
in it's so ugly so yeah I was looking
into mirrors and I want to get those
mirrors are a lit up like within the
mirror I don't know you know what I'm
talking about but then I started looking
into how to install it and I'm like oh
my god me an electrician for that stuff
I don't know we're gonna have to wait
till your dad comes back to help us
install that mirror yeah so the vision
for this bathroom here is new mirror may
be getting a different vanity thingy
where there's like cupboards and stuff
this is gonna be going away or if I
don't do that the cheaper alternative is
getting the little cabinet thing that we
have in the master bathroom upstairs
putting it here to put like toilet paper
away and then this wallpaper on this
whole wall that's a project we are
working on oh yeah update on Isaac's bed
by the way uh so it was almost
impossible to get a hold of IKEA they
only have one way to reach them and
that's through like my phone and then I
at them I sent them D and I sent them an
email from the business like to their
business singing whatever I did all this
stuff right I finally got ahold of
someone then they said ok no worries
we'll send you the two boxes that you're
missing for the bed frame and then it
was supposed to be delivered yesterday I
didn't get any phone call no email no
nothing need a call
try to call and look into that but Isaac
still does not have a bed frame it's
been over a week like a week and a half
I think since they said they were gonna
send it so I don't know what's the deal
with that well today's the day we're
getting the cut yeah yeah I haven't
received any notice for that but at
least I got armoire and then also our
blinds like what the heck it's been a
minute and we haven't gotten any updates
on the blinds okay it's quarantine
lifestyle everyone's kind of like I
totally understand that but I think
communication is important too you know
if you're not trying to to do it then at
least let us know you're not trying to
do it's not just keeping us like hanging
okay yeah we gave a deposit hey though
right are you look at my socks Oh Julia
gave me these socks for Christmas
oh no sorry it wasn't Julia it was Nikki
Nikki gave these for Christmas well
crazy cat lady to another yeah Julie
it's not crazy cat ladies but nikki is
look though you look like we saw okay
what's the first thing we should do this
oh okay we get too tired be like we're
gonna put it off to tomorrow we should
just take this paint hug I know that I
think we should
the pictures that we said we were going
to do yesterday that means even put it
off to today we should so before you put
off everything so tomorrow we should
just get everything done now
yes let's do it Rekha oh that's too much
I don't know about that - two things
today yes today I will play Minecraft
afterwards and do all right crap we're
so much more industrious in the
Minecraft world because it's easy or do
you want to die on the same you bring it
up
[Music]
[Music]
okay now you're gonna push on the dollar
yourself three - no yes
okay - okay
I don't know how we did this and I
almost died but we got to the top of the
steps in terms of this landing here
would still need how many thuds what
were you two three three more steps
you're about to die yeah it was I'm
pulling my back this is a lot more than
I'd ever did lifted when I was
weightlifting that's for sure
oh yeah Isaac you came through man yeah
I know we honestly could have done this
without you dude you're such a good
helper like I said in that other vlog
you're like the world's greatest helper
thank you I grabbed it immediately and I
I did this joking towards you thank you
because I really felt like I was about
to die I'm like okay well the corner
virus didn't get me it was my armoire so
I think we're good with the dolly you
just have to figure out how to get it
out is what I want to do now which is
lay it onto this platform I turn it and
lay it down yeah and and we just shove
shove it over the carpets my partner
should help us light it easier that's
true the box is also slightly wet you
guys can see but because it's raining
outside when they delivered it it kind
of got wet so we're trying to avoid the
carpet getting nasty like this whole
time that I was like lifting and stuff I
think kind of dried out a little bit
it's a lot of that oh very good sweating
that's why I'm sweating
that's what nice my feet are starting
this
[Music]
yay no it sucks but it's yeah heavy duty
[Music]
all right what's going on here now I am
now screwing it into the wall so it's
nice and safe but it's a little tricky
I'm gonna drill into the Wardrobe that's
cuz all my head's are strip yeah another
update I took off all my nails and I
filed them all the way down because the
nails that I had those were my natural
nails I didn't have like tips on it so
they were really really long and now
they're really really like then so I
can't use my not for anything which
means I can't take it out of this
thinking up my hand down yes useful
whatever you still stripping
I got it nice thanks my helper you're
welcome Ivan ish yeah Mel's like secure
knots nice and safe for toddlers like
you get it go and try yes that's exactly
one fireball no I don't want you going
huh this thing was there's a pretty
penny so you gotta take care of it
look how pretty it is though just ignore
the ladder ignore it ignore this look
through the ladder look at this this
beauty
look at this beauty look at this beauty
Oh talk about your muscles oh my god now
I get to put the shelves I the fine go
hurry up don't oh you know actually what
would you want nice because I was like
you're gonna fall through the bottom of
the horse you know this is quality
quality this is some quality stuff
tada
and hey what happened to the rug it was
supposed to come in yesterday but we're
supposed to have a rug right around here
and then we're gonna hang something up
there sake hello neighbor
yeah are you living on your hello
neighbor
dream no I want to get scarred for life
what do you think I like it really makes
this house close to the wall back thing
is now makes this couch seem really far
away from the wall true it's cuz we need
the clearance for for when we lay it
down like a bed but maybe it won't look
that bad once we hang the thing oh yeah
I'm just gonna busy it up a little bit
yeah oh yeah another thing because I've
read this to show you guys we added a
trash can in here look at that for all
of our snack trash and then we put some
blankets in here you know it's late so
the reason why I wanted to buy an
armoire or like a wardrobe whatever here
is because like I said we thought we
were gonna get rid of this but now we're
not anymore I mean it still looks good
it's like a nice statement piece up here
I like it I like it alright it's
lunchtime
it's burgers and leave this walk it
looks kind of gross now but it's so
decent
now we got some fries I think you made
yours you guys looking at we're talking
about actors and acting and actors
needing to like learn everything and do
everything and take things to the
extreme and like method acting whatever
sounds like Christian Bale loses way
forever
to show them like I was like fine
Christian Bell which one's Christian
Bale he's like oh wow oh my gosh that ad
is funny put the ad it knows you're a
man I know that's funny but yeah look
that's something else I did is I moved
that thingy and then I moved it over
there eventually the plan is to get rid
of that thing when we start selling
stuff but for now it's like okay go over
there go in the corner this looks way
better you like it you like it huh
you ready to eat sweets you ate it
I haven't gotten to any let me get
something anything at the rest is you
Madoka nanny what's up with this that's
a lot of salt how do you hook up your
barriers so the reason why it looks all
watery is because we were trying to like
keep it from browning oh yeah so we
layered the top of it with water but
then it just like the more we did it the
more watery er got it's hard to spread
it now hard
it looks like peeling or it's hard I
know it's hard to transfer to the
guacamole from the on the knife from the
container to your bread without a glue
like like goofing off yeah that happens
I should use sour cream to make you
sorry Thank You sour cream spread Oh
true you should have a guacamole sour
cream mix premix and I feel like that'd
be a great combination because I'm
Mexican food it's already like side by
side anyways they always have sour cream
and guacamole like side by side mix it
yeah but then when I eat it I mix it I
went to bars I was trying to spread it
without using the butter knife mmm
oh wait I forgot the mustard
you should put a smiley face cuz you
know are you gonna forget you know I use
the chopsticks so if you don't get our
fingers dirty and we don't contaminate
these I've been together more would you
do a dare I'd like you to something I
don't know what too much sodium oh yeah
didn't you catch up for this right there
[Music]